اجتماع وزاري لدول حلف شمال الاطلسي في
بوخارست اضافه الى وفد اوكرانيا يهدف الى
حشد الدول الاعضاء لتقديم مساعدات جديده
الى اوكرانيا وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني قال
انه اتى بطلبات محدده في الاجتماعات
السابقه للحلف تتعلق بتامين اسلحه للجيش
الاوكرانيه وقال انه حاليا يطلب من الدول
الحليفه ان تتعامل بشكل اسرع مع المطالب
الاوكرانيه للتصدي لروسيا نحن بحاجه الى
دفاع جوي ايرث
ونحتاج الى محولات عندما يكون لدينا
محاولات ومولدات سنتمكن من استعاده نظامنا
وشبكه طاقتنا لتوفير ظروف المعيشيه كريمه
للناس
الدفاع جوي سنتمكن من حمايه البنيه
التحتيه من الضربات الروسيه القادمه
من المساعدات الاوكرانيا وقال ان الرئيس
الروسي يستخدمه الصواريخ والمسيرات كي
تكون اوكرانيا بارده ومظلمه هذا الشتاء
تهامه باستخدام الشتاء كسلاح اليوم تم
تقديمه تعاهدات اضافيه لحزمه المساعدات
الشامله من الناتو اليوكرانيام سيقدم دعما
عاجلا لا يشمل سلاح لكن سيشمل الوقود
والمولدات لتتمكن اوكرانيا من التصدي
لعواقب ضربات الروسيه على شبكه الكهرباء
في مجال الطاقه يمكن ان تصل لاكثر من
مليار دولار مسؤولون امريكي
تتراس مجموعه السبع الى اجتماع على هامش
اجتماعي حلف شمال الاطلسي بشان ازمه
الطاقه